- Hey good humans, it's Jason and Jada
the director of this video.
- We just wanna give a quick
shoutout to our sponsors, Jaanuu.
They're the ones that
provided the awesome scrubs
that our doctors are wearing, and the ones
that we currently have on, right now.
- Honestly, my parents always wanted me
to be a doctor, growing up.
That never really happened
but had I known you could wear
comfortable scrubs like this everyday
I would honestly reconsider.
- [Jada] Be sure to stick around
so you can see how you
can get your first pair
of Jaanuu scrubs, but until
then, enjoy the video.
- When you guys were on call
what was your least favorite
thing to be woken up by?
- I got a little bit annoyed
with the Tylenol call
but I had to do what I had to do.
- I did have to see a
patient for herpes in his eye
so that wasn't very pleasant.
- [Everyone] I am a doctor.
- [Jada] Five are posers,
one is the real deal.
In a room full of liars
can these teams find the real deal?
- So, how are we feeling?
- Oh, we're feeling
good, we're feeling good.
- Yeah, I feel like maybe a little more
confident than I should be,
now that I get a look at you.
- Mhm, they ain't ready, they ain't ready.
Okay, numbers one through
six, in that order
could you tell us your specialties
and what school you went to?
- I'm a dermatologist, and I went to UCI.
- I'm a urologist and I went
to University of Tennessee.
- I'm an emergency doctor,
and I went to UCF as well.
- Physical therapist, Rutgers University.
- I'm a pediatrician and I
went to Drexel University.
- I'm an optometrist and I
went to Southern California
College of Optometry.
- Number six, can you tell
me what 20/20 vision means?
- Yeah, so basically,
it's kind of complicated
it's all like physics to it,
but there's a certain angle
that's subtended by
the letters that are on
the Snellen chart that you're looking at
and so they standardize
that at 20 feet distance.
So if you're 20/20, you're seeing
what somebody should be seeing at 20 feet
but if you're 20/30,
what somebody could see
at 30 feet, you need to be
standing at 20 feet, in order to see.
- When you guys were on call, what was
your least favorite
thing to be woken up by?
- During my residency,
I actually had a case
of Steven Johnsons.
And that was very scary to see.
- A large accident, with
fatalities it's always
a grim scene to come into
especially when children are involved.
So that's the worst thing
that I've had to do.
- I got a little bit annoyed
with the Tylenol call
but I had to do what I had to do.
- My emergencies are mainly
during a practice or real game.
I had like, ankle injuries
that needed to be lowered inflammation
with ice packs, or
certain massage therapy.
- I think just seeing any babies in pain
and then seeing a tragic
loss is the hardest thing.
- I haven't been on call as much, honestly
but I did have to see a
patient for herpes in his eye
so that wasn't very pleasant.
- I think, you thinking what I'm thinking?
- You thinking what I'm thinking?
- I'm thinking what you're thinking.
We're ready to make an elimination.
- [Jada] Each team will
try to find the real deal
by eliminating the imposters.
If both teams eliminate the same person
they will be removed from the game.
- When you asked about why they don't like
being called at night.
That was so sad, and the children
and this general thing
I was like "Okay that's nice
but nah." (wrong buzzer sounds)
- How long have you
been practicing, since -
well, you're still in residency, so
since out of residency?
- I've been out of residency
for a little over a year.
- I graduated in 1993 and
went right in to work, so.
- Twenty-eight.
- I graduated medical school in 2021.
- I've been practicing for fifteen years.
- I finished my residency at
USC Medical Center five years ago.
- And I've been out of
school for one year.
- Doctor number one, I have a question.
For the medical terminology intra vs inter
since you're a dermatologist.
What's the difference?
- Yeah, so it has been a
while since I've been in
medical terminology, but
I definitely use inter
a lot, and that would be inside
and then intra - gosh, I don't
remember off the top of my head.
- Doctor number four, can you name me
the different kinds of cruciate ligaments?
- Three, you said three?
- However many there are?
- Oh, you have the anterior, interior,
the meniscus, those are the main three.
- Gotcha, doctor number three
what system is the lymph nodes apart of?
- The lymphatic system.
- Are we allowed to eliminate two?
- [Jada] No, just one.
- Okay.
(doctors laugh)
- [Jada] As a reminder, if both teams
eliminate the same person, that person
will be removed from the game.
- When I asked him to name
me the cruciate ligaments
and he answered with -
- Meniscus.
- Which is not a cruciate ligament.
As a physical therapist, you
should probably know that.
- Doctor number five, could you tell me
a common medication that you
prescribe for one of your patients?
- Betnovate, it's for
babies that have fibrosis
before they get circumcised,
we try that method first.
An average is like, fifty milligrams.
- Doctor number five, I
had a question for you too.
For a baby under twenty-eight days
if they had a fever, how much
motrin would you give them?
- Ideally, none.
(ding)
- Ooh, she knows her stuff.
Okay, okay.
Go ahead.
- Doctor number six, if
the patient had glaucoma
what kind of prescription
would you give them?
- You could give them something called
latanoprost, so it's an eye drop.
You do that one at nighttime only
in whichever eye had the glaucoma.
- And then what would be
the abbreviation for nighttime only?
- QHS.
(ding)
- Our resident, number three.
Could you tell me what a
normal blood pressure is
and then kind of explain to
me what those numbers mean?
- 120/80 and then 120 is
the systolic, so pretty much
the amount of blood that's in the chamber
before it's ejected, and
then the bottom number
is basically the resting volume.
- One and four, could you tell me
what kind of cars you guys drive?
(doctors laugh)
- I drive a Toyota Highlander.
- So I have been driving the
same car since I was fifteen
I drive a Hyundai CRV.
I am still paying off medical school
so I will be driving that until
it cannot be driven anymore.
- I think we're ready to
make another elimination.
- [Jada] In this round,
both teams have decided
that one person is
definitely not the real deal.
Number four.
- I'm gonna miss you.
- I would love to hear your wackiest story
from a patient, on the job.
Down the line, sorry I'd
love to hear from all of you.
- So we had a TikTok star in, one time
and when I entered the
room, he was standing on the
medical bed, filming something,
pretending he was surfing
so that was definitely very interesting.
- It was a vaginal aclusion.
She and her friend had
been playing with a bottle
and had created a vacuum,
therefor lodging the bottle
in her vagina.
- I had this elderly patient
she had some sundowning,
some form of dementia
but she kept asking me to
go to the bathroom with her
to show her a good time.
- A mother asked me is it
okay to put false eyelashes
on her newborn baby for pictures.
- For me, I had a guy come
in, 'cause he was playing
with a Nerf gun, and I
guess he got hit in the eye
and he ended up having traumatic uveitis
and then he got some glaucoma
as a result from that
so that was pretty crazy.
- Nerf or nothing, right?
All right, we're good to eliminate.
- [Jada] Doctor number two.
- Sorry, sir.
- Thank you.
- Bye, bye.
- So we eliminated number two next
because they were very
broad answers given.
It wasn't very specific to
what a urologist actually does.
- So this is a question
for doctors three and five.
You walk into the room, and
you see the patient's monitor
(imitates flatline) flatline.
You feel their pulse,
there's nothing there.
How many joules are you
going to shock them with?
Doctor number five.
- Five.
- And doctor number three.
- Two-hundred.
- Doctor one.
- It has been a while,
since I've been in the ER.
I am a dermatologist, after all
but if I remember
correctly, it's 150 joules.
- [Andre] Okay, and doctor six?
- Yes, I definitely don't
work in the emergency room
so I don't work with that, I'm not sure.
- [Andre] That's fair.
- That was a question
that everyone got wrong.
The answer is none, because
you don't shock asystole
but that's something medical
TV sometimes gets wrong.
Everybody comes in there
with the paddles ready to go.
- I don't know, I don't know who's
the real deal at this point.
- Okay, I have a question
for doctor number three.
So earlier I asked you
what system the lymph nodes
are apart of, you said "lymphatic system".
What's the major system
that it's apart of?
- I know that it recycles dead cells
and fights off infections, and whatnot.
It's like at the tip of my head
but I'm nervous right now, so I can't.
- [MD Fan 1] Doctor number
one, do you know what it is?
- I believe it's the circulatory system.
- Doctor number six, do you agree?
- The immune system.
- Sweet.
- Doctor number five, what
is the average heartbeat
of a newborn, versus a one year old.
- For a newborn, it's lower
so maybe like, 35 beats per minute.
It elevates by the time
they're one, obviously
so maybe like forty, forty-five.
- I'm ready to make an elimination.
- I'm ready too, yeah.
- [Jada] Doctor number five.
- She talked about the
heartbeat for a baby.
That gave it away.
- She answered that a resting heartrate
for a fetus or infant is thirty-five
which would be very
concerning, if it was that.
They'd be not alive.
- Okay, I think we're
gonna have a demonstration.
We're just gonna have doctor number six
do a little eye exam with
my pen light, on Andre.
And tell us what she's looking for.
- [Andre] Let's see what
doctor number six got.
Let's see if she's a pro or not.
- Let's see those skills in action.
(drumroll)
- All right, so first I'm gonna be
checking to see if your pupils
are equally responsive to light
and if they are equal, in terms of size.
I'm gonna do the direct response first
so just look straight
ahead for me, please.
(elevator music)
Cool, so when I shine
it between the two eyes
I'm looking to see if the
other one stays constricted
because that means that there's a good
communication between the brain.
So, that's what I'm looking for.
- Okay doctor number one
can you tell me what medication
you typically prescribe
to patients with cystic acne?
- Yes, so if the acne is bad enough
we're gonna put them on accutane
but that is a high risk
drug, so we have to make sure
that the women come in,
every month and give us
a pregnancy test, and
then I also recommend
to not drink very much when
you're on that medication
and that goes for men, as well.
- Last thing, does a bar of soap
clean the face, pretty well?
- It can, yes.
I have some patients
that don't even use soap
when they was their face
and they have beautiful skin.
It kinda just depends on your physiology.
- [Both] We're locking in the real deal.
- Doctor number six, what
is that machine called
that blows air into your eye?
- Yeah, so that's called
a non-contact tonometer.
It measures your eye pressure
to screen for conditions like glaucoma.
- The cones that are in
our eye, what do they do?
- So, they help you perceive color.
- What colors do you see?
- Okay, sorry I'm trying to think.
Red, green, and yellow.
- Doctor number three.
Talk me through intubating someone.
What are you trying not to
accidentally push it down?
- You're not trying to
push down the tongue
so it doesn't block the airway.
- I'm gonna ask one more
question, real quick
for doctor number one.
Somebody has a mole, they
wanna get it checked out
what are some things
they should look out for?
- So, changes in shape,
color, if there's any pain.
That's definitely something we wanna know
and throughout the mole
if there is different kinds
of colors and textures
that's something that we
wanna look at, as well.
- That is all I needed.
One of you is a real doctor,
the other five of you
are going to jail for
impersonating a doctor.
(doctors laugh)
- Those doctors look really nice, Jason.
- They really do.
When Doctor Neela, co-founder of Jaanuu
put on her first pair of
scrubs, she felt deflated.
The box-y baggy fit, really did not
inspire her to perform at her best
and that's why she created Jaanuu
to help ensure that healthcare
professionals everywhere
achieved their greatness
with comfortable scrubs
that allow for peak performance.
- [Jada] Their breathable,
antimicrobial fabrics
are wrinkle-free, moisture wicking
and allow you to be active and
move with zero distractions.
Jaanuu believes that
better care has the power
to provide a better world
so join them and reimagine
your own greatness.
- That's right, and today
for 15% off you first
pair of scrubs, you can visit Jaanuu.com
and use the code jubilee15 at checkout.
Now, enjoy the rest of the video.
- We think the real deal
is doctor number one.
- The dermatologist.
We think she was knowledgeable about
everything that she explained.
She didn't really know the
joules, but like she said
she's not in the ER very often.
- We think the real deal
is doctor number one.
She didn't fumble on any of her answers
and the more that she kind of got into it
the more I felt that she was a doctor
talking to me as a patient.
- [Jada] In the event
that both teams lock in
the real deal, the team that locked in
their guess first, wins.
If the lights on the floor turn green
that means that you have
chosen the real deal.
If they turn red, that means that
you have chosen an imposter.
The real deal will be revealed in 3...
2...
1.
- Ooooooh.
- What the hell?
Who is it?
- Yes, hello teams.
My name is Rebecca, I am not a doctor.
I was in the medical field.
My original plan was to be a PA
but then I left medicine.
I went and got my MBA,
and now I'm in marketing.
I stopped working in
healthcare four years ago
so it was a bit of a
memory, kinda situation.
I was an MA for a dermatology
and plastic surgery private office.
- [Jada] Because you were not able
to find the real deal, we will
reveal them to you.
- Oh, nice.
- Yeah, you were my second.
- Shouldn't have gone off of cones.
- Hi, I'm Nicole and I'm the real doctor.
I think, sometimes maybe the way I
speak can come off a little ditzy.
I don't know if that's just my own
persona of myself, but I feel like
some people don't really look at me
and assume that I could be a doctor.
I think that doctor number one
did an amazing job.
I literally would go to her.
- I was not expecting the medical fans
to come in so hot with
those medical questions.
So they definitely gave
us a run for our money.
We had a good time.
- I'm still bitter.
(both laugh)
That's all.
- Down between those last two.
So, I was - (sighs)